I really want to give a sincere before
we get started to everyone here in the
audience I really want to say thank you
for coming out to Prime video I really
want to give you a huge thank you for
doing this with us and to you guys for
first you guys I think are still filming
season two and for being here today to
to do this I really say thank you thank
you for having us thank you
thank you
so I have a million questions I want to
start with for the cast
um if you have a choice between spending
the day doing promotional photos or
being covered in the crud and dirt that
you were covered in in episode seven I
believe when uh Mordor explodes that
whole thing what do you choose is it the
promotional photo day or is it filming
with covered in dirt and crud I actually
loved the dirt and grime and also I got
really obsessed with what it was made of
and it's made of potato which I was
really surprised at really ingenious and
the people who are doing the breakdown
they're kind of like I've put an extra
bit of like potato starch in this it's
really sticking and kind of I love
seeing them getting like super excited
about particular textures they're
creating but it wasn't nice and it went
in your eyes opening my eye for that bit
was pretty brutal
um without it there's no promotional
photos so to take so I mean I I do I
think I think what's so special about
our show is that the even even that is
full of
Artistry like the even the way when
we're full covered in mud and all those
things it's just completely uh to the
detail to The Last Detail so for us as
actors and I know that we all feel the
same way inhabiting these characters in
a show that is so
fully people are obsessed over making it
real and and having uh you know Tolkien
come through life but also make it uh a
2020 2022 2023 2024.
um um for new audiences you know it's it
is an honor to even be covered in mud so
it is for me it is a tough call actually
it's a very good question
um I I mean the uh uh uh gorgeous
costume designer is here so I will have
to say being on set
I dressed
um now I'm all in for the for the dust
and the dirt
personally I haven't had a chance to
roll around in the dust in the dirt yet
I hope for some
so I'm gonna go with the the photo
shoots that are actually in a car park
for us isn't it yeah they're in a car
park it all looks very flamboyant
mountainous but actually we're in a cup
but they're good fun you get to kind of
play and and yeah and just Embrace and
enjoy the amazing uh visuals of your
character so yeah they're pretty cool
for the people on the end uh one of the
things that you guys both had to do is
you had to bring the second age to life
for the first time and I'm curious for
both of you if you could talk a little
bit about how you prepared for what you
wanted it to look like and the visual
style because you were setting up the
first you were opening this series up
and deciding on the visual look and the
there was a lot that you guys both were
responsible for for you know second age
the truth is that because it was second
age there was no any example to follow
we had to create a world from scratch so
basically we look at lots of um
references from art I remember remember
that we mentioned
each World each kingdom had to be very
particular and specific I think one of
the greatest things about working in a
show like this one a story like this one
is that everything tells a story like
every color every texture the use of
light tells the story so so you can you
can use the language of Cinema uh and I
say Cinema because to me it was like
shooting a film you can use the language
of Cinema to the maximum you know and I
remember we sat down and we talk about
lots of reference painters for example
the elves we had lots of pre-ref
highlights painters yeah all of those
were coming from direct references to
tolkien's influences as well as his
writing so we we use that as a start but
it also came back to the knowledge that
we had of the third age where characters
end up so we're at the beginning of our
Arc and rooting everything in the
natural elements and all the cultures
and races in their um environments and
and the natural elements of the world
and that was all coming from Tolkien and
we used the paintings to try and capture
some of the Poetry of the work and words
and I think you did that beautifully
we had some funny references for the
dwarves that remember that we saw a
Russian Asylum films from eisenstein
remember that and there was a lot of
tarkovsky things like weird things you
know yeah and it's all and looking back
we also looked at some of the
expressionist stuff you know the
neighbor lung and all that German and
Germanic mythology that Tolkien was
interested in
um King Arthur um the The Legend of King
Arthur was another major point so all of
it came into the sort of melting pot and
we distilled things and we had a thing
called the War Room which was a secret
little room behind many doors because a
lot of these wonderful people would turn
up and sometimes there wasn't you know
always a script you know to follow and
things so we created these environments
to try and you know with J.A and
everybody work through the language in
each section and pertained to a race and
that and we'd build all these sort of
like a mausoleum of artifacts really and
that we created and materials and things
were you know put there so this this you
know the Dwarven culture and the
materials what were they like in
contrast to the Elven ones and all of it
had a similar language but um created a
difference through the uniqueness of
each culture can I just say that room
was phenomenal it was our first glimpse
into
um Middle Earth and we've all heard of a
mood board right but this was a mood
cave all full of Kate's how Kate's brain
works
yeah yes yeah it's a complete mess
everything everything was on the floor
it was horrible no it was fantastic it
was incredible and and and instantly
when you see as an actor and you you
walk into
um a project like this and you just see
what you're about to be in it just
inspired I was inspired by it anyway
yeah and both of these uh brilliant
artists were for us the first
introduction to this job like as Kate
said in the early stages we did not have
scripts they were being uh you know
worked on and uh you know our
introduction heavily uh was the you know
the imagery and the storyboarding and
the past that ja will communicate to us
but also we began building characters
from Kate's uh designs you know we
started building that character with her
um and I mean to be fair they were
essentially complete but you were always
she also always had an ear for us and
there was a collaboration and those
costumes continued to evolve I was just
going to say it works both ways you know
it's only part of the process the
discussions that the director and I
would have my response to the script our
response you know building the designs
but you know it's only the beginning of
the journey and that you know
significant in the development with all
of these wonderful actors and to
discover their character because it's
not complete until they bring their
world and physicality to it and on that
note when Owen says he walked into our
room he didn't he pirouetted on point
that completely changed my vision of a
dwarf
so that's why you gave me metal boots
to keep my feet on the ground
yeah I'm curious for the cast what is a
scene that you can't believe you got on
your first take and which is a scene
that you figured this is nothing and it
took you all day I do one which was the
dinner scene with J.A but I thought was
going to be quite simple until you put
food in front of me
and
first I saw Jay
eat onto the set to say severe there's
food in front of you got to eat it so I
was like okay okay talk and eat talking
it we can do it talk talk eat move all
at the same time do the acting so I did
that and I was like this is going to be
fine it's going to be easy this is the
one scene that we've rehearsed we had
the script we didn't shoot for a year
later myself a wine and Rob who plays
elrond were rehearsing him flat having a
great time I was like this is going to
be a breeze eating eating eating yeah he
comes in pounding it I can hear the
footsteps I'm like
Jay comes in severe you're eating too
much please stop eating
all I can see is you chewing this lab
that's really good food actually
uh so yeah that was the one moment in a
scene that I felt
well done sorry about it
mine was when um when Gladwell is found
um by the people on the raft in the sea
and it was how I was dragged onto the
boat and the first few times Charlie
Vickers
um kind of had been working on that raft
so he's kind of feeling all like pumped
up and stuff and he pulled me up like
this oh
like as if it was the hardest thing ever
I was just like Charlie I'm gonna be an
elf I'm gonna be really light and like a
little feather and so there was like
lots of kind of lots of it was kind of
Elf wise I think you'd find the same it
was like how do you make it look Elfie
and you'd have to kind of watch it back
because and see me like oh I didn't know
how human that was but it definitely is
just the angle of everything and we
really had the ja really gave us like so
much time to kind of explore this and
and that was really invaluable my mine
is also on the vein of elvenness I think
of a nest I think um I one that I was
very surprised that we got one take is
that um did everybody watch the entire
show
on the spot
um so in episode three when I when I uh
jump and break that canopy situation
that's that's the take you know like the
one that we did
um and that took I mean that took months
of of preparing but the resets are so
intense that and also I'm like super
perfectionist and you have to have a
thousand considerations in the air and
whatnot so that was it I thought that
was gonna take forever but then the one
um the one um in that I thought was
going to be more of a breeze was the
scene by the well
um episode one I think you guys watched
that uh because I mean I have been
auditioning with that with versions of
that scene for almost two years
um so I was like I got this in the
pocket but the aspect of elvenness how
to
um
how to evoke those feelings through the
structure of that being of uh being
essentially Eternal not being human a
person that a being that feels
differently that has all these curiosity
that love and romance or romantic love
is coming from a completely different
place and still keep it stoic and
distilled and and
Elven
um that was a challenge and still at the
end I wasn't I I didn't know what I'd
done and I felt that it had been
terrible and whatnot
um but yeah those that challenge uh was
through the season how to how to live
through the Elven
um being period
um
I know that uh the rock breaking
competition took a while because we had
like 50 60 essays there that was that
was um that I hadn't realized that I
would have to have shouted at Eldon than
at the dwarves and slam you know to slam
down on the Rock so much that was a long
that took longer than I thought it would
but I'm so happy that it took that time
because it looked incredible
yeah this is it I mean there are many
scenes that you think oh it's just a
two-hander it's just me and elrond it's
gonna be easy
that was a mistake
yeah because on top of the complexity of
these seals then you need to think about
the the complexity of the scale yeah
that we were learning as we were doing
it because those were the First episodes
yeah yeah there were so many times where
um Robert Romeo who plays elrond was was
up on a platform sometimes on a
stepladder sometimes a chair uh whatever
we could we could we could sometimes the
other the you know the pack with his
with a little stick come in he was it
was like a vest with a piece of stick
coming up the top and his face up there
so you can imagine between takes we're
walking at Rob's walking around kind of
forgetting that he's got his jacket on
it's like he's promoting himself like so
hey I'm Rob
that was that was an interesting
um version that we had to do just kind
of had to act with the promotional Rob
but yeah those scenes took a while
because when it then came on to Rob's
take
um I would have to be down on the floor
so I would either be on the knees or I
remember one in particular where I was
on a stool that had wheels and and
because my character walks around in the
same Rob's eye line needed to move
around as well but I couldn't take human
steps my steps they had to be Dwarven
steps and therefore the movement was
shorter so I was just kind of trying to
right just trying to slide around on
this that took longer than expected as
well
be here on a Saturday and to be watching
this they're a fan and everyone is going
to be watching the Q a uh which we're
filming is a fan so for fans what do you
think would surprise people to learn
about the making of the show that they
wouldn't know I do think we cared in as
much as every fan none of us took these
jobs on this job on or this project on
rather than a job we're all passionate
about the material and we've all had
opportunities to see it and read the
books and I think we all invested that
and we're always thinking of that as
part of the process but also trying to
find the language that worked for the
age that we were in and I think it was
always behind everything we did you know
the due diligence of bringing in
um you know within costumes we tried to
bring in
um Echoes of things artifacts from
gondolin and and in the Dwarven world we
we tried to bring everything we could to
keep making you know bringing depth to
the storytelling and things that we
weren't always possible to show so I
think we cared it was the biggest thing
hanging over us in many ways you know
yeah I mean yeah there are so many
details on set on the costumes and
um on little artifacts that that have so
much detail and they are what do they
call them Easter eggs
yeah there's like loads of eggs in there
that that haven't you probably
hit the screen yet
um but it's there's there's just lots of
stuff like that
[Music]
the one thing I will say and it is
negative it's the comfort of wearing a
beard
and the costume as beautiful as it is
it's hard work Kate
it could have been yes exactly yeah I
thought you liked me no you did you do
you do I wanted I wanted to go
um expand also on what Kate was saying I
think the fans um
should know that we are also fans and
that we approached it with that heart
and uh you know we were shooting this
through shooting shooting this this
through covet and the personal sacrifice
that came for us to be working on the
show is something that um you know it's
difficult to convey because we were all
away from home we were all essentially
locked in an island for almost two years
and this was our life and we and we made
it our lives and in onset rehearsal but
also our off days we would meet we would
talk about it there were Zoom groups
made out of our own accord or other cast
members of court because I was always
kind of lost to talk about uh Tolkien
and the
how immersed we became in this with the
fans in mind is something that I I I
hope that you all know and that the fans
know that this was truly a labor of of
love and respect and we just wanted to
do right by you all
so I think ja is going to say episode
one or two but because we are listening
here the actors and laughing and then we
are listening to Kate uh not laughing
but it's fascinating you to listen to
you and as a director you have the
feeling that you have everything because
you have the humanity here and then you
have all the knowledge and the talent of
the costume so it was very easy to be on
set and to be working and you you need
to imagine the level of
um challenge that we had in recreate the
second age for the first time on on on
the screen but being surrounded by these
guys here and this woman here make my
work a lot easier
I'm curious for everyone uh eight
episode first season which was your
favorite episode and why
that's why I said I think Jay is going
to pick one or two but you know
I think mine is the first episode
um and I think
for so many reasons but I feel that um
I feel the when I first watched that
even though I was there on these sets
that were so beautiful and I was wearing
these costumes that I knew were stunning
actually watching what we made nothing
will compare to actually that first
episode where I got to see that
um but also in terms of glad you're like
I love the scene
um with glad Jill and eldond
um just before she's kind of sent to um
valinor
um when they're kind of speaking about
what it feels like to be a living
element of history and that we were like
just as a fan that we were next to all
those trees that had all these kind of
elves carved into it that we kind of
recognized um
I think that will always that first
episode
um will always hold just kind of just
pure magic for me
um yeah and Ja was just he created that
for us it was amazing oh it's so hard a
tricky question it's such a tricky
question
which one was the favorite favorite I I
think it's gonna have to be up to
because
it was the beginning it was as I said
that that scene that we did had been
played for a year by myself Rob and Owen
in a flat that hug between Diesel and
elrond was crafted
in a hotel room on a dining room chair
while our wine is cooking us chicken
sandwiches like and that and he was like
right I'll get up on this chair so we
can
that's my that's my black accent
um so that we can really see how this
hugs gonna go and it was hilarious and
it made it in the show because it came
from such an authentic place of our
friendship and our hilarity and our just
playing and I guess
that episode for me and particularly for
us was the beginning it was it was the
Genesis of the dwarves as we see them
now and and actually I think the first
time that obviously we've ever seen them
in this way so alive so kind of present
and
um
with so much depth and that was our foot
in that was our okay here we go here are
the dwarves here is kazadum awake uh for
the first time and I I think the
beginning of that and of course to be
led by this Genius of a man
um for me was Unforgettable it was also
my major kind of like TV debut I'd done
theater my whole entire life so to step
onto a screen of which I kept on walking
on by accident before they said action
because in the theater world you know if
they're silent you get on there's a
problem you just walk up and do
something and uh so I think there's a
few moments of Silence so I just kept
boldly walking on
Rob was like yeah
so uh I think it was like my biggest
learning it was It was kind of where
disa really got to kind of flex her
muscles and say okay I'm here I've
arrived and um uh yeah so I'll never
forget that also genius bit of costuming
of the Dwarven children in that oh I
love them I'm from practical needs
stop with them for crash bags of that
scene really like don't attack
but no they were great they were very
cool I think I knocked
yeah and it stayed in because because I
lifted him up and and he he hit his head
while he hit his helmet into into the
lampject
and that was that was that was that was
a mistake yeah yeah I just didn't know
how tall I was
I think my favorite what is yeah I'll
second that episode
I've got two can I say two sure okay so
two and two and seven
are my favorite is because two was is
the establisher for us for our world and
that first time working with J.A and as
I got to do everything I got to be
intimidating I got to be a leader a
prince you know a hero Rock breaker
an eater a belcher a husband husband and
uh and you know and then then I get I
get emotional with with my best friend
so it's like I got the range I I I was
allowed to go through there being a
dwarf as well was such a gift and to do
it with J.A playing We Will Rock You
music over there
in the scene was great but seven
kind of I hold quite close to my heart
because it's it's the it's the the
payoff really or the heartache of of the
entire season for
um for the dwarves and and so shooting
that and exploring that and kind of
getting into the depths of it and
um and then looking back and watching it
back and all the work that
everyone had created
um that's that's a favorite as well
so yeah I'm gonna I'm choosing two two
and seven as long as long as you're not
saying episodes one through eight you
know what I mean yeah yeah I mean I love
I love that every episode especially the
ones where I have more screen time
um so those are my friends and he's not
lying
absolutely not
um I mean don't you love that though
he's like well I love the episode where
I'm there for 30 seconds said no actor
Ever
um but I um we worked with fantastic
we're fantastic directors with um each
director had just magic and and just
passion but you know as I'm I'm hearing
things um the response is and it's not
just because ja is here but I had I mean
I personally I had we all had different
stories of how we came to the show I had
this long audition process and within
the process I had you know several
rejections to the role and I kept
fighting to be in the show and and kind
of obsessed not obsessed but very
committed and determined to be in the
show for what it represented that I'm
sure you all know I mean the first half
of color and all these things and the
big
um representation aspect of it all
thank you and um you know we do it for
the people uh and but it was such a
journey and and it was such a personal
Journey that I feel I Was preparing for
this role for like 20 years since I
first saw the first movies and it was
you know a personal uh desire of mine to
to be that elf despite all of the
rejections along the way those 20 years
as well because it happened to be
laughable to some people so there was so
much writing on it and I knew that I
mean later on um
you know one of my Champions behind the
scenes
was J.A and I heard the stories and I
heard that later on you know that I I
would some people be like no he's not
right for the role and then maybe a few
months later Jay would be like what
about that guy you know and and bring
and bring my headshot back into the
conversation because I knew there was
somebody fighting in there I was
fighting on the other side telling my my
agents no we're not going to take no for
an answer I'm gonna show up at jbayona's
like office they were like don't be so
creepy and I I but later on
later on when we met because I was
brought to New Zealand after like my
third and final rejection Something
Turned and then suddenly I was asked to
to go and I I just knew when I when I if
I presented myself to them and and we
met that they would see what it was that
I believed in myself that was for the
character and it was immediate we met on
the set and just to do the test and
immediately I mean it was strategic but
I was like que pasa because I knew
because I knew you spoke Spanish so
we're like blah blah blah blah
you you act with people that you know
there's directors and there's directors
both JM Berlin received what I had to
give with such respect and it was you
know when it lands and they believe in
you and I think we all had this
experience
um that that you feel respected you feel
seen you feel
um grounded you feel that that there is
that belief in you and in all your story
and all your history and that's how I
felt in that in that audition and then
to have my debut in The Lord of the
Rings world with with J.A and be
shepherded by him
was the right thing it was just the
perfect thing so episode one
[Applause]
because I'm in it a lot
uh Jay and Kate do you have uh the
favorite
I I'd really prefer to say instead of
choosing an episode that I to me to be
the director of the first two episodes
is very strange when you leave the show
because uh
you don't finish the show you just start
the whole thing but and it's like kind
of like Bittersweet feeling you know but
the truth is like watching the rest of
the episodes and seeing the thing coming
alive it's like like having them the
feeling that all the things that you
were preparing for so much time for so
long they were working that was uh
that's that was a pure joy to me I'm
going to cheat and be a little bit like
J.A and that it wasn't a single episode
I think in the process of creating and
working with all these different groups
every every new character or group of
characters and costume took on
um you know the whole crew got invested
in and you saw it through to
um to this to um on set and that so that
became you sort of fall in love with
that bit and then the next one comes in
and then you discard that one yeah
embrace the next project so you know
it's always a you know creating these
things and then giving up your lollies
and moving on to the next one it's sort
of a little bit of what you said but
it's just the
um all of it sort of it's more moments
and things or that little bit of costume
prop or or that moment where everything
tied up together it's sort of when I
look back it's more sort of moments
within the process and that that made it
and the collaboration all the time
really for me a lot
so one of the things that floored me
when I was watching the series was the
bellrog uh oh and has heard me say this
about a thousand times
um what was it like for you guys reading
some of the things that were in the
scripts for the first time because I
don't know how much you were told you
know going in this is going to be what
happens in season one and for me like
seeing the Bell Rock I was you know
obviously really F and excited
um yeah I mean it's it's you know
obviously the the balrog is something if
you're Gateway into Tolkien were the
movies then then the ballad is like oh
my Christ
um so it was so to to kind of to have
him live in the cellar is kind of it's
kind of I feel like yeah it's a good boy
he's not that bad he's not that bad he
said don't feed him when he's on the
chain and he'll be fine
um but nah it is one of those moments
that that it's a pinch me moment where
you go all my life I'm in Lord of the
Rings you know I've had so many of those
moments on on this show you just need to
walk onto the set to see all the
Artistry around you to kind of you this
is nowhere other than Middle Earth
and then you immerse yourself into it
but yeah it was it was a pinch me moment
is there
no I'm in Lord of the ranks
I just I I'm I'm truly Blown Away by the
scale and scope of the series but I want
to actually touch on uh Kate I want to
talk a little bit about the costumes
because they're so incredible and I'm
curious what it's like working with
actors So you you're designing costumes
what is it like the first day like
you're going in to see the costume and
how much does it change from what you
envisioned to what the when the actor
puts it on and what they're giving you
feedback on can you sort of talk about
what it was like for the cast to try on
costumes for the first time and Kate how
does it that collaboration sort of go
uh is that you starting no you start
because we talk for a very long time
lovely production designer said I'm so
glad I don't have to work with actors
process everything's a process and a
collaboration and you know we all have
different interpretations or a vision of
something and you know that's part of
the process and you know we went through
many iterations of things you know I
didn't just put an image on paper and go
here you go I mean sometimes I do but
but you know it's and I didn't it took a
while because of the secrecy and that to
know who was in there so who was cast so
you know a big part of that process is
putting the structure in for each world
and creating the rules for each culture
so we sort of had that to hang on
because once the the things moving you
have to move very fast and you know you
have to be ready to give up your lollies
and you know change your mind or adapt
some of the ideas as everyone comes to
be part of it you know Owen prancing in
on pirouette changed my vision of a
dwarf and Sophia and it was all about in
the end it was just about how do we
create this character together and some
of the ideas stayed and developed and
became more and others shifted and
changed it's it's a constant process of
giving things up and moving along so you
have to kind of have your big story and
then sort of tap dance really fast
through the process as we're working
together but you're not you can't make
all these decisions in isolation and
they're cast for you know reason and
what they're going to bring to these
characters so I have to sort of listen
and be party to that and just there's
all the psychological there's the bigger
world that they're in and in contrast to
other characters it's about supporting
them supporting the script and that's
the main job of a costume designer and
how are these characters in The
environments you know we always had to
look at the environment and and in a
very practical way with scale but also
just in terms of the poetic language of
Tolkien how do these characters fit into
those worlds and Jay and I worked a lot
together on that and with Ramsay and
with visual effects it was a it's a big
process of collaboration so you can't be
an island
yeah the collaboration was so massive
for me like because always say this like
you can't imagine how silly you feel in
your joggers in some little like office
room trying to rehearse gladriel like
she just isn't there
um and
getting the ears getting the costume
getting the makeup that's when she
really kind of lives and I remember so
Kate is the most incredible artist and
um I I remember going into your magical
war room and you'd drawn like the armor
but with my face and I think that was
the first time I really believed that I
was like oh there she is and I'm there
too and that was kind of an amazing
moment of kind of me believing myself
because someone else could see it
um and yeah and I think the moment we're
kind of had that final fitting for the
northern waste armor which is just
incredible like if we're talking about
before like details the details of that
armor for it to look like it had been
used for a thousand years is just
absolutely wonderful but there was the
head of every department and your whole
team there
um and it was one of the Privileges of
my life to kind of where these peoples
are and be translated so many people on
her at the first yeah we couldn't see me
it's like having an octopus kind of
working on you all these arms
um yeah but it was just wonderful and
it's
um and then we'd have a fitting week I
mean there's new innumerable fittings
for something like this as many as the
stars in the sky but we you know we do
something and then we had a team of um
uh a team working on the chainmail
um so there'd be a team of eight hand
welding all the chainmail that we
ridiculously decided would be perfect
and took a long process but you know it
was constantly back and forth and
adjusting and also adjusting on a
practical level and for illusion in
certain moments so there's lots of
things that you know for this moment we
need it to work like this and then
there's a stunt work and and always it's
got to be part of a back and forth
discussion you know I'm talking about
that sorry yeah talking about change and
what you did Kate holy I remember
working on DSA how D says costume came
alive with the brilliant Kate was
there was actually a draft do you
remember for for months there was a
draft of disa and it was quite um
everything was very covered and it was
gorgeous and it was wonderful and I
remember we went away at covid we had a
lockdown in New Zealand so everything
shut down for a little bit and then I
they said okay we're back up and running
time passed and we walked I walked into
Kate's room
okay it was like okay we're abandoning
that that we've done for the last few
months what happens if we make diesel
really sexy why are we hiding her why
are we hiding your skin why are we
hiding your your body and your
vivaciousness if we have so much Stone
why can we not make her water that kind
of moves across that stone of all the
the characters I think you know she's
she's really kind of showing her
confidence in her skin which
for me not being at a smaller woman as
we've seen in these kind of iconic roles
before it was just I couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe that somebody saw
her beauty in that way
um and thus Desa was born with like a
massive slit up her leg golden eyes to
embark on her magic and her gift and um
it all started from something that was
really covered that was abandoned and
just said we must celebrate her and we
must celebrate what isn't ordinarily
celebrated in in um in such a princess
so yeah sort of um you know classical
world again it was actually discovering
that within the world of what talking
was looking at looking at classical
references you know nibalon all of that
world it was all sitting there it wasn't
like we were imposing a modern
um take on that but also you know seeing
her as Duran sees her you know and the
love that they you know there's such a
wonderful relationship and and and
feeling the earthiness of of desa's
character and that it felt important to
do that and I think when you're dealing
with scale and you know the idea of a
dwarf there we had you know been through
a processes before with fat suits and
God knows what and covering everything
up and in a practical way we couldn't do
that with dwarves on the timelines that
we have we couldn't have endless
Prosthetics and that so it was sort of
distilling it around in a different way
and and playing with the language in a
different way that led to that so
sometimes the Practical solution can
also become a creative one and vice
versa so there's a constant play all the
time and you always have to sort of
change the way that you're doing it and
some some answers that worked came out
of that process is it obvious that we
love them
one thing I mean when I you asked like
how it felt when you first we first saw
ourselves in costume I I mean
all over the storyline that I've given
you guys about the process that was so
special you know after and again we had
the process of fitting and stuff like
that and I was I was a little slightly
difficult yeah I have a lot of ideas I
was like no I don't like this and this
doesn't move in there and she said just
trust the trust what it is you know just
trust what it is what it what it's made
of what it feels like and I started to
to give into that that costume that
actually like informed me so much but
when I first saw myself in in costume I
just had this massive improbably large
single tier that just like but it's it's
what more that said it's like you've
arrived you've had lots of bits of
cardboard attached to you at the
beginning
the process being a little less
believable yeah but it but it was great
and and she said she was sitting on the
couch and kind of paint you you know
what if you drape this here no no
what if we drape this here what if we
drape that there what if we take this
out and just like in in real life kind
of painting and sculpting you and it was
just brilliant and my one of my favorite
parts that I think it's in quenion right
that it says uh and for the fans like
little trivia my um
my arm abrased thank you so much my arm
it's it's
um says may your arrows always sing and
that was something that you just came up
with and like kind of get from a text
you know it's from the world yeah but
but it's a nice moment to you yeah but
but it was something that you just had
it there and it was like this is just so
you know your nana was like so special
because internally that really that
really impacted me yeah I love you Kate
it was really hard to dress them really
hard to dress them